[تصفيق]
لقد بدانا حفلتنا النوويه واسرارنا ستظل
داخل احشائنا فلتفتحوا ابواب مخازن
اسلحتنا بهذه الطريقه خطب بوتين حلفا
النيت وامريكا ووزاره الدفاع الامريكيه
لقد رصدنا غواصه روسيه قرب السواحل
الامريكيه وزيرنسكي سقوط بخموت يعني خسرت
اوكرانيا روسيا تصرح بان السويد ستصبح
هدفا مشروعا لها
لا مكان للولايات المتحده في النظام
العالمي الجديد وبطون مخازن الاسلحه
الامريكيه خاويه فاين ذهبت كل تلك الاسلحه
اوكرانيا تتهم امريكا بسرقه المساعدات
الاوكرانيه ايعقل هذا والصين تقول كلمتها
الاخيره بخصوص تايوان واشنطن تعترف بعجزها
النووي امام بكين مجنون كوريا الشماليه
يتجول في اسلحته مغرنا عن دخول بعضها الى
الخدمه وامريكا توقف قانون غزو العراق لكن
بعد ماذا يا هؤلاء والسعوديه توجه صفعه
اخرى للولايات المتحده وبوادر الازمه
تندلع بين الكيان الاسرائيلي وامريكا
روسيا تعلن عن مفاجاه عسكريه مارد الاسلحه
الروسيه يخرج من قمقمه ليبحث عن اهدافه
الغربيه جنه جنون الروس وظهرت قوتهم
المرعبه التي اخفتها موسكو لسنوات فها هو
الجيش الروسي يبدا تدريبات بقوات صاروخيه
الاستراتيجيه ليستعرض قدراته نوويه
بالتزامن مع الحرب في اوكرانيا حيث اجرت
موسكو مناوره عسكريه بصواريخ يارس
البالستيه ويعد يارس صاروخا بالستيا عابرا
للقارات براس النووي ويبلغ مداه حوالي الف
كيلو متر ويشكل العمود الفقري لقوات
الصواريخ الاستراتيجيه الروسيه فلما
تخرج لهذه القوه في هذا الوقت ليعلنها
نائب وزير الخارجيه الروسي
لن تبلغ الولايات المتحده من الان فصاعدا
بتجاربها الصاروخيه فما الذي يخبئه الدب
الروسي هذه المره ليجيب قاده عسكريون
امريكيون بتحذيرهم من اندلاع حرب بحريه
موقده قرب السواحلهم لا تطفئها مياه
المحيط الاطلسي وذلك مع اقتراب الغواصه
الروسيه النبويه جاسم من البر الامريكي
هذه الغواصه مصممه لمهاجمه حاملات
الطائرات القتاليه ولتدمير الغواصات
المسلحه الجحيم الروسي يقترب من الاراضي
الامريكيه اليكم المصدر
حضرت قاده العسكريون الامريكيون من اندلاع
حرب بحريه موقده قرب سواحلهم لا تطفئها
مياه المحيط الاطلسي وذلك مع الغواصه
الروسيه النوويه من البر الامريكي الضغط
الروسي يتواصل على امريكا واذا ما نجحت
روسيا والصين في تحقيق خططهما فقد لا يكون
هنالك مكان للولايات المتحده في النظام
العالمي الجديد وفق صحيفه واشنطن تايمز
ليخرج وزير الخارجيه الصيني قائلا ان
روسيا والصين ستحققان السلام والامن
العالميين المصائب لا تاتي فرادى
للامريكيين حيث ان التزام امريكا بدعم
اوكرانيا قد زعزع استقرار المخزون المحلي
من الصواريخ والذخائر خاصه الصواريخ من
نوع ستينجر المخزنه حتى انها ستحتاج الى
13 عاما بسعه الانتاج الحاليه لاعاده ملء
مخزونها بالكميه نفسها وذلك وفق موقع
بيزنس انس الامريكي ليزيد وزير الدفاع
الامريكي
الامريكان بالله باعلانه تعهد بلاده
بمواصله دعم اوكرانيا مهما طال الامر
مضيفا ان فرص مسيرات الامريكيه معدومه
امام دفاعات روسيا هناك قال وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه
تدعم الجهود الدبلوماسيه الراميه الى
تحقيق السلام في اوكرانيا فهل حان وقت
ايقاف الحرب بعد كل تلك الخسائر الامريكيه
ومن جهود السلام الى ضجيج اصوات الرصاص
ورائحه البارود التي تجوب اراضي اوكرانيا
حيث اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه مقتل اكثر
من 500 وخمسه
ليقترب موعد معركه الربيع التي طال الحديث
عنها كهجوم مضاد اوكراني والتي قد تنطلق
في ابريل ومايو المقبلين بحسب وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني لكن قائد القوات البريه
الاوكرانيه الجنرال الكسندرسكي صرح ان هدف
المدافعين الاوكرانيين في بخموت استنزاف
قوات العدو على حد قوله اما الرئيس
الاوكراني
فقال صريحه بانه اذا هزمت القوات
الاوكرانيه في باخموت فان كييف ستخضع
لضغوط كبيره من قبل المجتمع الدولي وستضطر
الى التسويه مع روسيا بحسب وكاله السوشيال
بريس
ان الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين سيعتبر
سقوط بخموت نصر خاصا له وسيبيعه لشعبه
والغرب والصين وجميع البلدان ليستطرد
قائلا انه مستعد للتحدث مع الرئيس الصيني
وانه وجه له الدعوه لزياره اوكرانيا رصيد
المقاومه الاوكرانيه ينفذ يا ساده فهل
تنقذ الصين ما تبقى من الاراضي
بالحوار زللنسكي عاد وصرح بان اوكرانيا
بحاجه الى 20 بطاريه من انظمه الدفاع
الجوي باتريوت لم تتسلمها حتى الان برغم
ان قرارات تسليم المنظومه قد صدرت ولكنك
لا تمتلكها في واقع الامر وفق قوله بحسب
وكاله
السوشيالنسكي لن ينهي حديثه بعد واردف
قائلا من بلاده ستتعرض للهزيمه اذا توقفت
الولايات المتحده عن مساعدتها مؤكدا ان
واشنطن تدرك ذلك لكن لماذا خص الزلميسكي
امريكي بتحذيره هذا الاجابه جاءت باعلان
رئيس لجنه العلاقات الخارجيه في مجلس
النواب الامريكي مايكل ماكول ان اوكرانيا
تحصل على 20% فقط من المساعدات الماليه
التي تقدمها واشنطن بينما يتلقى الجانب
الامريكي حوالي 60% للقوات الامريكيه
والعاملين الامريكيين ولتحديث المخزونات
الامريكيه من الاسلحه والمعدات العسكريه
فيانم كم يا ابناء العم سام تدعمون
اوكرانيا فقط في وسائل الاعلام بينما
الدعم ما هو لقواتكم
وبالعوده الى روسيا اطلقت موسكو تحذيرا
شديدا لهجه للسويد بقولها ان انضمام ستوكه
يجعلها هدفا مشروعا لتستدعي السويد سفير
روسيا لديها احتجاجا على التصريحات
الروسيه اليكم المصدر
السويد تستدعي سفيره روسيا لديها احتجاجا
على بيان نشر على موقع السفاره الروسيه
يقول انضمام ستوكهون الى حلف الناتو
يجعلها هدفا مشروعا
ومن السياسه الروسيه الى الاقتصاد حيث
قالت نائبه رئيس الوزراء الروسي
من اكثر من ثلاثه ملايين ونصف المليون شخص
في روسيا خرجوا من دائره الفقر منذ العام
2017 وذلك بفضل اجراءات الدعم الحكوميه
وفقا نيفوسطي
شوكه صينيه في الحناجر الامريكيه
ولا عهد المنافسه واقتربت امريكا من حرب
الملاحقه نعم واشنطن تبدا ملاحقه التطور
الصيني المخيف هنا رئيس الاركان الامريكيه
المشتركه
بعجز واشنطن عن منع او ابطاء تطوير الصين
قدراتها النوويه مؤكدا انها ستسير وفق
خطتها في هذا الجانب للسنوات العش القادمه
لينتقل اصحاب العيون الضيقه نحو الجزيره
التايوانيه مع ازمه جديده تلوح في سماء
العلاقات الامريكيه الصينيه المتكدره
اساسا على خلفيه توقف رئيسه تايوان في
نيويورك خلال توجهها الى امريكا الوسطى في
طريق عودتها حيث اعتبرت بكين توجهت ساين
نحو امريكا انتهاكا صارخا لمبدا الصين
الواحده مؤكده انها سترد بحزم حال اجتماع
رئيس مجلس النواب الامريكي
برئيسه تايوان في امريكا الاحداث
والتطورات
تزامنا مع وصول حامله الطائرات الامريكيه
الى السواحل كوريا الجنوبيه لمواصله
التدريبات العسكريه المشتركه بين واشنطن
وسيول كشفت وكاله الانباء الكوريه
الشماليه عن الرؤوس الحربيه الجديده التي
اطلق عليها اسم هو سان 31 وها هو الزعيم
الرؤوس الجديده او كما يقولها المصريون
بعين الصمت الجديد لنكمل وذلك في زياره
لمعهد الاسلحه النوويه متعهدا بانتاج
المزيد من الاسلحه النوويه ايدت اغلبيه
اعضاء مجلس الشيوخ الامريكي تشريعا يقضي
بالغاء التفويضات التي مضى عليها عقدان من
الزمن للحروب السابقه في العراق لكن ماذا
سيستفيد العراق من الغاء هذه التفويضات هل
ستعوضون خسائره الفادحه من الارواح
والدمار وفقت السعوديه على الانضمام
لمنظمه شنغاي للتعاون التي تقودها الصين
بصفه شريك للحوار في اشاره جديده الى
تزايد روابط المملكه الخليجيه مع البلد
الاسيوي العملاق بايدن يدعو رئيس وزراء
اسرائيل لايجاد حل وسطي حقيقي للازمه يرد
اسرائيل مستقله تتخذ قرارتها من دون ضغوط
وتدخلات خارجيه لكن نتنياهو عاد بعد تجديد
واشنطن لهجته نحو تل ابيب بسبب التعديلات
القضائيه ليقولا ان التحالف بلاده مع
الولايات المتحده لا يتزعزع غواصه روسيه
نوويه تقترب من الاراضي الامريكيه فهل هو
تهديد روسي صريح بواشنطن ام ان هناك مارب
اخرى لموسكو
[موسيقى]